[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña nuestro asesor científico el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez para hablar
sobre la aplicación de dosis de refuerzo
de las vacunas contra el kobe 19 que ya
se están empezando a implementar en
varios países mientras que en otros
todavía se evalúa si en realidad son
necesarios y sobre todo quienes la van a
recibir doctor muy buenos días es normal
que las vacunas contra el coi 19
requieran más dosis de las que ya se
habían planeado inicialmente es normal
que estas se apliquen tan seguido además
entre una y otra
en los virus respiratorios hemos
aprendido que las vacunas tienen alguna
periodicidad para reforzar el sistema
inmunológico sobre todo por lo que hemos
visto no es por el virus sino por los
cambios que genera estas variantes en
donde la inmunidad tiene que reforzarse
esto desde el momento que se lanzó la
vacuna es una posibilidad y cada vez es
más evidente de que se requiere con
alguna periodicidad incrementar y
reforzar la vacuna para que los
anticuerpos incrementen y cuerpos de
generar la protección pero ahora después
de una tercera dosis o una segunda en el
caso de johnson and johnson es posible
que se requieran más dosis en un futuro
digamos que en este momento estamos
estableciendo un tipo de inmunidad que
se llama moral que es mediada por
anticuerpos y esta es la que se está
reforzando sin embargo los estudios en
desarrollo están evaluando la inmunidad
de otro tipo que se llama celular y es
la que da la permanencia de la
vacunación todavía no tenemos estos
datos y no podemos saber si después de
la tercera dosis habría necesidad de
otro refuerzo probablemente si sería si
existirá una variante interés que se
escapara a los anticuerpos de esta
vacuna pero hasta el momento es
conducente sólo hasta la tercera dosis
todos no sabemos qué pasará en el futuro
doctor y frente a esto le pregunto si
una mayor cantidad de dosis es sinónimo
de mayor inmunidad
no raúl y acá no es el número de dosis
sino el tiempo en que se administren
obviamente tener más vacunas estimula el
sistema inmune y para eso tenemos que
estar seguro que es es que ese estímulo
que sea el sistema inmune también sea
seguro por eso el número de vacunas es
un número que es limitado que es
periódico no es vacunarse todo el tiempo
y se debe evaluar el estado inmunidad
para poder saber cuándo se debe vacunar
esos pasos hasta ahora se están dando y
por eso tenemos que primero asegurar la
pauta completa y el refuerzo en las
poblaciones que lo necesitan ahora al
dejar de aplicarse una dosis de refuerzo
estamos entonces comprometiendo la
inmunidad que ya habíamos adquirido con
las otras inyecciones
no las vacunas y la pauta completa de la
vacunación nos asegurando una inmunidad
la tercera dosis hoy es evidente que las
personas mayores de 65 años y las
personas que tienen algún trastorno en
sus defensas que toman medicamentos que
tienen cáncer vih enfermedades
debilitantes requieren ese refuerzo aún
no está claro si las personas inmuno
competentes vayan a requerir una dosis
adicional o en cuánto tiempo la puedan
requerir por eso tenemos que tener lo
primero completar la pauta completa en
la mayoría de personas establecer la
tercera dosis en unas poblaciones
especiales y luego si miraremos cuándo
va a ser el tiempo mejor para que
nosotros las personas que no tenemos
estas alteraciones recibamos una tercera
dos doctor una pregunta muy popular y
además con escasez de vacunas que se
vive en nuestro continente y en nuestra
región sobre todo se puede utilizar la
dosis refuerzo de una vacuna diferente a
la que ya se nos aplicó
es una buena pregunta porque hay una
cosa que se llama paute heteróloga que
es la pauta heteróloga es que se coloca
una vacuna y otra distinta marca eso se
ha establecido en vacunas como
astrazéneca y falset países y moderna
también son medicamentos que pueden ser
alterna bles y se están evaluando las
otras posibilidades pero hasta ahora la
que está aprobada digamos o la que está
más estudiada es astrazéneca málaga una
de facer o las vacunas de pfizer y
modernas que pueden ser intercambiar se
está estableciendo por ejemplo lo que se
hace en chile y en uruguay la vacuna de
sinovac con el refuerzo del freezer y
estamos muy entusiasmados en que van a
salir los reportes pronto de cómo sería
esa inmunidad y si se logra con estos
refuerzos para poder implementar en
otros países así es doctor y por lo
pronto puedes vacunarnos y esperar
entonces las indicaciones de nuestros
gobiernos locales para en el caso
eventual entonces de aplicarnos esta
inyección de refuerzo contra el coi 19
en este caso doctor muchísimas gracias
como siempre por estar con nosotros y
usted también gracias contribuyen
france24
[Música]